here's what would happen if everyone  turned off their lights at the same time  now we're told to do this every year for  earth hour but is it benefiting the  planet as much as we think  well it's complicated one of the reasons  we try to do this every year is to  reduce our carbon dioxide emissions that  are harmful to the environment but  turning off our lights doesn't actually  help as much as we think  if we decide to light candles once our  lights are off we could potentially be  emitting even more carbon dioxide into  the atmosphere  and although we usually think of this  hour as a way to give power stations a  break once we turn all the lights back  on the sudden increase in demand would  mean firing up more generators  this would emit even more carbon dioxide  than usual so  is turning off all our lights really a  good idea well